Welcome, welcome, welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. Thank you for watching.
Oh, awesome. -Happy birthday!
-Thank you. I appreciate it. Thank you.
It's my birthday. Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, it's funny. I forgot how old I am.
'Cause you reach a certain age and you forgot how old you are.
It just happens. So I go -- Yeah, I'm, uh...
You know, I'm 49 or whatever, you know.
And so that's great. The card's -- "You're 49."
I go, "I don't think I'm 49, am I?"
And they go, "Yeah, yeah, you are."
And so my daughter goes,
"Alexa, how old is Jimmy Fallon?"
[ Laughter ]
Alexa -- "Jimmy Fallon is 48 years old."
It's like -- "That's the best gift ever!"
You gave me a year of my life back!
I have a whole year ahead of me for free!
Let's get to some news, you guys.
Last night, President Biden
did a rare sit-down interview on "60 Minutes."
I don't know if you saw this.
And he made a pretty big announcement.
In case you missed it, here it is.
-Is the pandemic over?
-The pandemic is over.
We still have a problem with COVID.
We're still doing a lot of work on it.
It's -- But the pandemic is over.
[ Laughter ]
-It's kind of huge news to mention so casually, you know?
I wasn't expecting the end of a two-and-a-half-year nightmare
to be announced on the floor of the Detroit Auto Show.
It's like hearing, "I had a good day.
Went for a run, ate breakfast, the baby was born, you know."
[ Laughter ]
Apparently Biden's comment was not part of his planned remarks
and caught several of his own health officials by surprise.
Dr. Fauci was like, "Oh, God.
it's 2020 all over again. Oh, my God."
For the rest of the interview,
whenever Biden answered a question,
a staffer quickly revved a car engine.
He's like, "That's right. We're going to go to war with Ch--"
[ Engine revs, tires screech ]
"We're gonna support Tai--"
Later in the interview, Biden, though, was asked about his age.
Watch this.
-Mr. President, you are the oldest president ever.
-Pretty good shape, huh?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-He handled it pretty well, yeah.
Although, I will say it got a little dicey after that.
Take a look at this.
-How would you say your mental focus is?
-Oh, it's focused. [ Laughs ]
I say -- I think it's -- I -- I haven't -- Look.
You think I would tell you if I knew exactly?
Of course I'm not going to tell you.
So I -- Look. This is a process.
This is a process.
And the proof of the pudding's in the eating.
I mean, don't -- don't -- don't.
My point is, it takes time. How's an old guy do that?
I no more think of myself as being as old as I am
than a fly.
-What do you mean?
-No.
-No, man. Yo, yo, yo. Yo!
-That's edited, right?
-No. -Alright. Thank you.
-That's a joke. -No, that's not real.
-Oh God.
[ Laughter ]
-Props to our editors there.
Well, I saw that this weekend
former president Trump spoke at a rally in Ohio,
and at one point during his speech,
music started playing,
and his supporters reacted in a pretty strange way.
Check this out.
-And a Department of Justice that refuses to investigate
egregious acts... [ Grand, sweeping music plays ]
...of voting irregularities and fraud.
And we have a president who is cognitively impaired
and in no condition to lead our country.
-Not creepy at all.
Then Trump was like,
"And now to sacrifice the first-born sons.
Come up here, Don Jr."
[ Laughter ]
What was going on?
Meanwhile, Trump just returned to Mar-a-lago
for the first time since the FBI search,
and he's complaining that FBI agents
didn't even take off their shoes before going into his bedroom.
Yeah, for some reason,
the agents weren't like, "FBI! This is a raid!"
[ Laughter ]
"Should have wore Velcro."
Of course, everyone is talking about this today --
leaders, dignitaries, and politicians
from around the world gathered in London
for the funeral of Queen Elizabeth.
Meanwhile, Trump showed up at a Burger King
and said, "Sorry for your loss."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Two whoppers. French fries. Diet Coke."
[ Applause ]
In observance for the funeral,
flights in and out of London's Heathrow Airport
were canceled or delayed.
LaGuardia heard that and was like,
"Uh, that's also why our flights are, uh..."
[ Clears throat ] "Out of respect, of course.
We're gonna be respecting till, like,
around New Year's, probably. That's what was...
We'll continue our respect. Yeah."
Some entertainment news -- we're just one month away
from the release of Taylor Swift's
10th studio album, "Midnights."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And fans are already finding all kinds of secret messages
about the album in her social-media posts.
-Oh, man, all that stuff is just conspiracy theories, though.
-Uh, I don't know, Tariq. The clues are --
The clues are everywhere. -What clues?
-Okay, so, Taylor made a surprise announcement
at this year's VMAs that her 10th studio album
was gonna be called "Midnights"
and it would come out at midnight on October 21st.
You follow? -Uh...
-So, 13 is Taylor's favorite number,
and "Midnights" is gonna have 13 tracks on it,
but nobody knows what the songs are called yet.
On all the album art she's shared so far,
all the songs have fake titles
like "Track One," "Track Two," that kind of thing.
-And that means...? -But when she posted a video
announcing all of the limited-edition vinyls,
the names of the songs were all blurred out on the covers,
so you can tell the songs won't actually be called
"Track One," "Track Two." And that was on September 1st.
Then on September 16th,
she posted another video revealing
that if you line up the backs of all the special-edition vinyls
with the regular-edition one, it makes a clock.
Midnight is a time on a clock.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Okay, well, I guess -- -Yeah, but here --
here's where it gets interesting.
In Taylor's entire discography,
she's only sung the word "midnight" in six songs.
She sings it in "Style" off of "1989,"
"You Are in Love" off of "1989,"
"New Year's Day" off of "Reputation,"
"The Last Great American Dynasty" off "Folklore,"
"Happiness" off of "Evermore,"
and, of course, in "22 (Taylor's Version)"
off "Red (Taylor's Version)."
[ Laughter ]
And that's not even the crazy part.
'Cause it also turns out she's sung the phrase "middle of the night"
in seven songs throughout her discography.
She sings it in "...Ready For It?" off "Reputation,"
"Daylight" off of "Lover,"
"You Belong with Me (Taylor's Version)"
off of "Fearless (Taylor's Version),"
"Untouchable (Taylor's Version),"
"All Too Well (10 Minute Version) (Taylor's Version)"
off of "Red (Taylor's Version),"
"Better Man (Taylor's Version)"
and "Nothing New (feat. Phoebe Bridgers) (Taylor's version)"
off of "Red (Taylor's Version)."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What are you even saying?!
-Six "midnights" plus seven "middle of the nights"
equal...13.
13 is Taylor's favorite number.
That's how many songs are on "Midnights."
Taylor's a genius!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what.
You get it now? -Yeah, I get it.
Happy birthday. -Thank you. I appreciate it.
Well, this is going viral.
Guys, an 80-year-old state Senate candidate in Utah
named Linda Paulson is going viral
because of a new campaign video that she just released.
Can we see this, please?
♪♪
-Oh, no.
-♪ Hey, Utah District 12, listen up right here ♪
♪ There's a new name on the ballot ♪
♪For the Senate this year ♪
♪ My name is Linda Paulson, Republican and awesome ♪
-Yeah. -[ Laughs ]
-At that point, the Tupac hologram unplugged itself.
[ Laughter ]
It's like if "Hamilton" was written by Mike Pence.
Doesn't it kind of...?
And finally, guys, do you ever see a photo in the news
and think that headline should be different?
Well, we'll take care of that right now.
It's time for "News and Improved." Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example, check out -- check out this first photo here.
The original headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"No one's getting fired."
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ] "Oh, yeah. This was back..."
-"I coulda. I didn't. But I coulda."
-"I didn't, but I coulda."
"Are you sure?"
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Wow!
That's a headline.
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
[ Applause ]
-And finally, this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all the time we have for "News and Improved." We have a great show.